on YouTube was that that's that's
mainstream right there that stuff works
calm that's as mainstream as you can get
what does that mean you know what's
mainstream the JRE this is mainstream as
[ __ ] hell yeah his mainstream is [ __ ]
now he downloads a day what does
mainstream mean it doesn't mean it's not
real
how does because was a conspiracy theory
and I'm like no no that's not what I
said I said the conspiracy to keep this
quiet the fact that the government's
nuclear tests most likely killed John
Wayne and a shitload of actors from
[ __ ] cancer in the desert they were
dropping bombs not knowing with the [ __ ]
they were doing and there's plenty of
evidence that they didn't know what the
[ __ ] they were doing yeah if you watch
the videos of old nuclear test site with
soldiers running towards the blast yeah
I've seen those yeah [ __ ] insane
looks like it looks like I don't know
just like all that old footage looks
like it doesn't look authentic it looks
like they faked all that [ __ ] what about
I you know there's a conspiracy theory
that that nuclear bombs actually don't
exist that they never actually figured
it out but they realized that the threat
of nuclear bombs is good enough but
Eddie you can see the bomb ever see the
one where they drop the bomb in the
ocean and they didn't know how much of a
blast it was just a regular powerful
bomb like how do you know how do you
know by watching along the nuclear test
I don't know what a nuclear bomb looks
like when it blows up I don't know
irregular no listen we have things that
can test nuclear you say how do you how
can you tell I know if you can do title
you can do tests with those insured I've
never done those like you you can't I
don't know
something that your studied in I'm
saying oh I know but I'm saying no no
but I'm telling you you how can people
look at a bomb
you're saying someone else figured it
out how can you look at a bomb and tell
[ __ ] the wrong way it was really do no
I'm just saying if there was a videos of
20 bombs going off would you be able to
pick out the nuclear bombs Eddie they
make these giant mushroom clouds they're
very unusual it's not like a regular
bomb I'm not saying that video say Bobby
ocean how can anybody tell like a
regular you ask a question I think you
should probably talk to a nuclear
physicist question what I don't know but
to question it like it's not real is
ridiculous they killed how many [ __ ]
people in Nagasaki and Hiroshima [ __ ]
how do you know watch this watch this
bomb there's still half look at this I
don't know how do you know if that's a
bomb that that is the craziest amount of
power you could ever imagine I could
never imagine something that can blow
the ocean of the mana into the sky
okay and that's just one video of it
there's another one of those videos
where they do it from a distance where
you look at the water where it's falling
from I get see if you can find one you
understand it could be a nuclear bomb
I'm saying all I'm saying how can you
know for sure look at that how can you
know how many whales died in this Oh
everything died everyone they all the
fish they made some tuna salad out of
that [ __ ] all the fish are fun
look at the water come down how crazy
that is what that boats [ __ ] though
huh look at that look at that yeah I
don't know if what that is I don't know
look at that that's high that's big but
I don't know why question ventia no
bombs
it's well with different cuz Eddie's
Eddie sand the reason why they
threatened nuclear bombs keep everyone
kind of chill but we want to have the
you don't want to do that dude that
would wipe out a [ __ ] city but maybe
you could do that with just regular
conventional bombs maybe just maybe
that's like okay okay you know what I'm
saying is I don't know right well you
should find out I don't know by this is
this is a nuclear bomb okay and the
scientists all agree there's no
conspiracy those currencies amongst
idiots these people that are talking
about it online they literally have no
idea what they're talking about and
they're spread I don't know I don't say
I don't understand you don't know but
don't even bother question it's a waste
of time it's a so you're going down a
rabbit hole
for no reason you waste all this time
how do you know how do you know how do
you know I don't know what do you call
me well I could weigh I could waste my
time on whatever why are you so
concerned why are you so concerned about
me wasting money because you waste our
time too why why don't you want to find
the answer to it why don't you just want
to question that you could look up look
up yeah you could look up anything it's
not going to look up if you literally
want to know the answer to this
particular question you could look it
out no no no I'm not no no you could go
to college okay you could get a
professor you could find any number of
people that have the answers could show
you how to study them could prove the
test too you could lay it out could give
you all these instructions so you could
go do it on your own without anybody I
don't care about it that much then why
then why again then just chose one
person question I just don't trust
anything I can't verify for myself but
you you don't have to get mad you could
say that why are you mad because that
you're getting mad right now
[ __ ] from the government you can verify
this you just said you can't but you can
that's that's the issue on some of these
things with science they are have you
verified it yes their driveway I went to
[ __ ] physics class and wouldest
College I got an A okay so that proves
they own it today works I quit college I
didn't keep going down the nuclear klutz
farther in than physics 111 and 112 at
Ohio State they don't give it to the
freshman damn I think is high level
State that's it I mean if you want the
answers you can go get them it's not
just question this is why it's
frustrating because you don't want the
answers you just want to question
everything that the in air quotes
government says what are you so angry or
not it's frustrating
why because world being flat because
nuclear bombs being fake because
dinosaurs not being real those things
are crazy they're a giant waste of time
for who for us more time let's talk
about something else okay but you will
like talking about those things
hey I didn't bring up nuclear bombs you
guys did I didn't bring it up but you
really argued it for a while I'm just
bringing up questions and you're getting
angry not angry Eddie okay good do you
hear me being
you guys sounded angry said you were
frustrated as Frost frustration it
usually is is in there with anger anger
I'm just saying it the the the one fun
point Eddie was making is like man I
don't know nuclear science or anything
like that so how do you know those that
are bombs a real computer regular bomb
it was a fun conversation that's it just
makes up your [ __ ] calves Jamie Game
seven tomorrow morning turning game
seven game LeBron you can look into a
lot of this stuff and you can't find the
answers that's all that's my only point
and when you're talking over me that's
where the frustration comes from that's
it you're angry
I'm not angry angry at this time telling
people did not get angry you using that
as a defensive tactic because he's
making a good point because I'm not
saying people are angry ok you you got
you say it's frustrating so as we say
it's my three because you don't believe
in the government you're angry I don't
trust the government you could say that
we can said why are you angry I said I
do say that no we could say that thank
you
we could say why are you angry that
doesn't get anybody anywhere we're just
talking about the reality of these facts
you guys can believe whatever you want
all right I will okay I believe
everything I've been taught and learned
go right ahead
I think that isn't frustrate me I don't
care what you think
what am I am I wrong then no you could
believe whatever so why would you
continue to question it hey Brennan
that's a nice shirt Hey